All right, so this
is the final challenge.
[music playing]
It's a six pack of obstacles.
NARRATOR: Caesar works with
Millie, a seven-month-old doxon
whose habit of eating
trash off the ground
could have lethal consequences.
CAESAR: This is serious.
This dog can actually get hurt.
NARRATOR: Caesar's final
test will determine
if owner Britney has the
confidence to lead her
through a simulated minefield.
CAESAR: Don't say a word.
Just kind of guide with
energy, body language.
Ready?
I don't know that she's
going to do that with me.
That's not something that we--
Well, then let's
make it happen.
Got to see it in your mind.
I want you to remember, the most
important as you're starting,
is calmness.
It's more about you
teaching yourself
to be calm, to be patient.
Yeah.
All right.
All right, let's do it.
The calmness.
Yeah.
Ready?
Let's try this, Millie.
Let's go.
Nice.
Slowly.
[millie whines]
Just give a little more space.
Not so much tension.
We've talked about it.
We've gone through it.
So I'm aware of everything
that I need to do.
CAESAR: Keep coming.
But actually putting
that into motion
and keeping myself
in a calm state,
that's the thing that I'm
actually most nervous about.
[millie whines]
CAESAR: A little too close.
That's the obstacle there.
She can't touch.
Slow it down.
It's stressful to walk her.
[millie whines]
Remember, with the leash, the
tension should last one second,
two second the most, right?
OK.
CAESAR: It's just to
direct or to stop.
Relax the hand.
Yes, yes.
And you have to remember
to control the nose.
You guide the nose and
the dog will follow.
Keep coming.
Walk in the park.
Stop right there.
Sit there.
Yes.
Beautiful.
Right next to it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah,
she's doing it.
She's doing it.
Come on, keep going.
Mhm.
Yep.
Then you go.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Yeah!
Yay!
I felt like a proud mother.
The first time this dog has ever
attempted half of these things,
and she just did it.
Flabbergasted, actually.
Yeah.
Oh, that's the
best, right there.
That was a sloppy kiss.
That was a sloppy kiss, yeah.
I feel pretty proud.
Now I realize how much
my stress and anxiety
was really weighing on Millie.
And that's such a simple
change to get Millie to stop
eating things off of
the ground, and it
makes me hopeful for
where we can go from here.
So let's celebrate,
but wait for me.
Cause I really want to
celebrate it the weenie way.
I want to celebrate
the weenie way!
I was waiting for this day.
This is the way you
celebrate with a weenie dog.
That's right.
I'm a Mexican hot dog.
What do you think, Millie?
[millie whines]
This is actually the first
time I put a costume for a dog,
by the way, and I think
Millie deserves it.
Because this case
was pretty serious.
We don't want bad weenies.
This is how people think of you,
by the way, the weenie dogs.
Weenie dog.
Caesar, thank you
for everything.
I could not be more happy with
the training that you gave us.
I'm not afraid to walk her.
We are absolutely leaving
here today on the right path.
We did it.
Yep!
Yes.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Let's go.
All right.
Come on.
Two weenies.
I hope we win an Emmy.
[laughing]
[music playing]